welcome back i will now introduce you to
the concept of momentum
momentum and the letter for momentum is
in physics and or at least in mechanics
is the letter p p for momentum
and i assume that's because they the
letter m has already been used for mass
which is i guess an even more
fundamental idea so p for momentum
so what is momentum well you probably
have a a general idea of it i mean
people if if if you see a big guy
running really fast they'll say he has a
lot of momentum and if there's a big guy
running really fast and a small guy
running really fast most people would
say well the big guy has more momentum
without maybe maybe they don't have a
quantitative sense of why they're saying
that but but they just feel that that
must be true and if we look at the
definition of momentum it'll make sense
the definition of momentum is equal to
mass
times velocity so something with say a
medium mass and a huge velocity is going
to have a big momentum
or something with maybe a medium mass
but
the other way around i forgot what i
just said so medium mass and big
velocity huge momentum or the other way
around huge mass medium velocity would
have maybe the same momentum but still
have a big momentum or another way of
viewing momentum is how little you would
like to be in the way of that object as
it passes by
how little would you how uh
how unpleasant would it be to be hit by
that object that's a good uh
way of thinking about momentum
so momentum is mass times velocity
and since well let me let so so what how
does it relate to everything we've been
learning so far so we know that force
is equal to
mass times acceleration right
and what's acceleration well
acceleration is just change in velocity
right so we also know that force
is equal to mass
times
change
in
velocity
per unit of time
right
per change in time
t for time
so force is also equal to
well mass times change velocity mass
let's assume that mass doesn't change
right
so that could also be viewed as the
change in
the change in mass times velocity
in the unit amount of time right and
this little trick here i said you know
the mass times the change in velocity
that's the same thing as the change in
the mass times the velocity assuming the
mass doesn't change
and here we have mass times velocity
which is momentum so force
can also be viewed as change
in
momentum per unit of time
and i'll introduce you to another
concept called impulse an impulse kind
of means what you think it means and
impulse is defined as force times time
and i just want to introduce this to you
just in case you see it on an exam or
whatever
so it's not a difficult concept so force
times change in time
or time if you assume time starts at
time zero but force times change in time
is equal to impulse
i actually don't know i should look up
what letters they use for impulse but
another way of viewing impulse is if
force times change in time well that's
the same thing as change in
momentum over change in time times
change in time
right because this is just the same
thing as force
and that's just change in momentum
so that's impulse as well
impulse
and the unit of impulse is the joule and
we'll go more into the jewel when we do
work and all of that and if this
confuses you don't worry about it too
much the main thing about momentum is
that you realize it's mass times
velocity
and since force is change in momentum
per unit of time if you don't have any
external forces
on a system or want to say on a set of
objects their their combined
or their net momentum won't change and
that comes from newton's laws the only
way you can get a combined change in
momentum is if you have some type of net
force acting on the system
so with that in mind let's do some
momentum problems
whoops
invert colors
okay
so let's say we have
a car say it's a car
let me use some more interesting colors
a car with a magenta bottom
and it is let's see what does this
problem say it's a thousand kilograms
1000 kilograms so a little over a ton
and it's moving at 9 meters per second
east
so its velocity is equal to 9
meters per second
east
or to the right in this example
and it strikes a stationary 2 000
kilogram truck so here's my truck
here's my truck and this is a 2 000
kilogram truck and it's stationary so
the the velocity is zero
and once when the car hits the truck
let's just say that it somehow gets
stuck in the truck and they just both
keep moving together so they get stuck
together
the question is what is the resulting
speed of of the the combination truck
and car after the collision
well all we have to do is think about
what is the combined momentum before the
collision
well let's see the momentum of the car
is going to be the mass times the car
mass of the car
ma well the total momentum is going to
be the mass of the car times the
velocity of the car
plus the mass of the truck
times the velocity
of the truck
and this is before they get they hit
each other so what's the mass of the car
that's a thousand
what's the velocity of the car it's nine
meters per second
so as you can imagine a unit of momentum
would be kilogram meters per second so
it's a thousand times nine kilogram
meters per second but i won't write that
right now just to keep things simple or
so i save space
and then the mass of the truck is 2000
and what's its velocity well it's zero
it's stationary initially
so the initial momentum of the system
this is 2000 times zero is 9000
plus zero which equals nine thousand
kilogram
meters per second that's the momentum
before the car hits the back of the
truck
now what happens after the car hits the
back of the truck so let's let's go to
that situation so we have the truck
i'll draw it a little less neatly and
then you have the car and it's probably
a little bit
well i won't go into whether it's banged
up and whether it released heat and all
of that let's just assume that
that
that there was nothing
this is a simple problem that we can do
so if we assume that there would be no
change in momentum because we're saying
that there's no net forces acting on the
system and when i say system i mean the
combination of the car in the truck
so what we're saying is this combination
this this new vehicle called a car truck
its momentum will have to be the same as
the car and the truck's momentum when
they were separate
so what what do we know about this car
truck object well we know it's new mass
right the car truck object
it will be the combined mass of the two
so it's a thousand kilograms plus two
thousand kilograms
so it's three thousand kilograms
and now we can use that information to
figure out its velocity how well its
momentum
this this 3 000 kilogram object's
momentum has to be the same as the
momentum of the two objects before the
collision so it still has to be 9 000
kilogram meters per second
so once again mass times velocity
so mass is 3 000
times the new velocity so we could call
that i don't know new velocity v sub n
that will equal 9000
because momentum is conserved that's
what you always have to remember
momentum doesn't change unless there's a
net force acting on the system because
we saw
moment force is change in momentum per
time so if you have no force in it you
have no change in momentum
so let's just solve divide both sides of
this by
3000 and you get
the new velocity is 3
meters
per second
and that kind of makes sense you have a
relatively light car moving at nine
meters per second in a stationary truck
then it smacks the truck and they move
together the combined object and it's
going to be to the east
the combined and we'll do more later but
uh you know we we assume that a positive
velocity is east if somehow we ended up
with a negative it would have been west
but it makes sense because we have a
light object and and a stationary heavy
object and when the light object hits
the stationary heavy object the combined
object still keeps moving to the right
but it moves at us at a at a relatively
slower speed
so hopefully that gives you a little bit
of intuition for momentum and that was
not too confusing of a problem and in
the next couple of videos i'll do i'll
do more momentum problems and then i'll
introduce you to uh momentum problems in
two dimensions
i will see you soon